moi quand j'étais pompier de paris
c'était sauver ou périr voilà j'ai si
c'est dans notre adn et là du jour en
main mais je me retrouve pas je peux
plus de pompiers parce que ça mon métier
mon expérience il ya eu deux injections
[Musique]
je faisais à peu près 1000 euros la
caserne là bas ce qui était suffisant
pour bats pour mes enfants en fait pour
mes gamins puissent ça leur paye les
études je vais je suis pas une période
persona rixe à risque mes enfants encore
moins et on va les obliger à faire
vacciner
[Musique]
vous êtes pompiers pendant trente-trois
bourges ou en inde à vous et plus rien
en fait tous tous deux avaient fait
avant ça non plus alors dans ma tête
c'est très clair je serai jamais plus
pompiers voilà j'ai fait le deuil
je suis pas payé son jeu retrouvé un
travail sas étudiants mais mieux vaut
vous voulez retrouver voilà il ya pas de
problème mais voilà c'est ça tous voient
toute notre vie assez cool de rien en
fait
[Musique]